[Musik]
ja liebe hörerinnen und hörer ich
begrüße sie und euch ganz herzlich zur
folge
189 des einspruchs podcast heute am 8 12
20 21 einem ganz besonderen tag an dem
nämlich ein neuer kanzler gewählt wurde
darüber wollen wir heute auch sprechen
und zwar mit corinna budras im gang und
die box geht ja wir sind heute mal
ehrlich das hat wirklich auch lange
nicht mehr glücklich lange aber es hat
sich so ergeben den pia lorenz ist
natürlich immer noch im urlaub und
helene du bist ja auch öfter ohnehin
hier zu hören deswegen dachten wir
werfen wir uns beide mal in die
waagschale und wir kommen gleich zu den
themen denn oder sagen wir besser zu dem
thema dennoch wie gesagt heute ist der
machtwechsel im kanzleramt dafür übergab
oder wie immer man das nennen möchte und
deshalb sprechen wir über alles was
damit zusammenhängt und wir werfen auch
einen vertieften blick in den
koalitionsvertrag
dann haben wir natürlich noch des
infektionsschutzgesetzes lässt uns ja
nicht los da wird es jetzt in sachen
impfpflicht auch ernst der das zu den
themen und wo wir heute so kurz und
knackig sind kann ich vielleicht noch
mal sagen dass wir uns immer freuen über
feedback oder
logische touren genau korrekturen oder
auch vorschläge es kann auch immer mehr
vorschläge für themen darüber freuen wir
uns unter einspruch podcast faz.de
und das verbinde ich gleich mit einem
aufruf unseren faz einspruch zu
abonnieren also das magazin dass es
online zu haben gibt da viele rechtliche
team eine sehr interessante themen zu
lesen sind und damit unterstützen sie
unterstützt ihr auch diesen podcast so
und jetzt geht es gleich los
[Musik]
denn los geht's vielleicht unterhalten
uns erst mal kurz darüber was heute
morgen und auch heute mittag im
bundestag und in schloss bellevue
passiert denn tatsächlich gab es eine
echte pendelt leyen zwischen bundestag
dann vor olaf scholz zum
bundespräsidenten dann fuhr er wieder
zurück in den bundestag und dann von
alle zum bundespräsidenten also das
ganze kabinett das neue und dann fühlen
sich alle wieder zurück in den bundestag
was ist passiert heute morgen um 9 uhr
begann die sitzung geleitet von der
neuen bundestags präsidentin bärbel bas
von der spd die also alle
abgeordneten aufgerufen hatte ihre
stimme abzugeben man konnte mit ja nein
oder enthaltung
ankreuzen alles corona konform so gut
das eben geht bei 736 abgeordneten und
das geht dann aber tatsächlich noch mit
einem kärtchen was man aus filmen und
echten stimmkarten die erwartung in ein
elektronisches gerät stecken muss
nein das wird angekratzt und dann
tatsächlich in einen eine wahlurne
geworfen
das zeigen
die abstimmung ansonsten im bundestag
sind häufig namentliche abstimmung aber
die wahl ich habe es jedenfalls so
gesehen dass da einzelne umschläge noch
die durften da hat sie extra hingewiesen
nicht fotografiert werden oder ähnliches
was hätte würde dann ja
zu sanktionen führen aber wegen verstoß
gegen das wahlgeheimnis aber die wohl
tatsächlich in waal umgeworfen und
ausgezählt das ergebnis ist natürlich
mittlerweile bekannt im ersten wahlgang
hatte olaf scholz 3 195 stimmen bekommen
allerdings hat er eigentlich die ampel
eigentlich eine mehrheit von 417 also 21
leute die eigentlich
den ampel fraktionen angehören haben
nicht gestimmt da gab sofort geraune von
der opposition was hat es damit auf sich
wahrscheinlich so argumentieren
jedenfalls die ampel leute sind es
einfach ein paar kranke insgesamt war
tatsächlich der bundes freund nicht
vollständig besetzt präsent sondern es
insgesamt ungefähr 29 abgeordnete kann
aber auch gut sein dass der ein oder
andere
fdp-mann oder vielleicht ein linker
sozialdemokrat oder ein der eine andere
grüne hofreiter denen auch düpiert wurde
spekulationen natürlich durch nichts
belegen können aber interessante schon
also 21 stimmen fehlten aber immerhin
die mehrheit ist ja sagten die mehrheit
ist ja da die sogenannte kanzlermehrheit
also die mehrheit der mitglieder des
bundestages also nicht der anwesenden
die an dem tag da sind sondern
derjenigen die gewählt wurden und das
sind eben
736 die derzeit im bundestag sitzen so
was ist dann passiert dann vor olaf
scholz rüber nach bellevue und so in
knappen kilometer musste mit dem auto
zurücklegen habe es im auto zurück ging
erhielt dort seine urkunde vom
bundespräsidenten die ernennungsurkunde
und fuhr dann wieder zurück in den
bundestag und leistete dort nach § 56
des grundgesetzes den eid
wo er im wesentlichen sagt ich schwöre
dass ich schaden vom deutschen volk
abwenden und seinen nutzen mehren werde
und so weiter am ende die gottesformel
sprach er nicht die ist auch so steht es
auf brücken grundgesetz optional und da
olaf scholz nicht mehr mitglied einer
kirche ist war es natürlich auch
konsequent dass er darauf verzichtet wir
hatte erste konfessionslose
bundeskanzler gleichen andere
bundeskanzler hat habe ich das vorhin so
gehört gab die auf die gottes gesichtet
haben genau und dann gab es wieder
gratulation das habe ich jetzt für mich
gesagt also blumenstraße häuft man sich
überhaupt standing ovations für oder
scholz auch übrigens für die kanzlerin
die er mittlerweile ex kanzlerin dann
ist die oben auf der tribüne saß wo auch
die familie von olaf scholz als seine
frau seine eltern und seine
schwiegereltern und seine brüder
gekommen waren seine frau muss man dazu
sagen es bildungsministerin in
brandenburg wissen vielleicht auch nicht
viele aber dass ein echter politiker
haushalt ja das kann man wohl so sagen
wir haben in hamburg angefangen als
politiker sie war damals glaube ich in
den aller ersten tagen noch irgendwie im
arbeitskreis sozialdemokratischer frauen
aktiv und ist dann auch relativ schnell
aufgestiegen und er auch also dass zwei
leute so rallye karriere machen wenn
auch er jetzt muss man sagen ein
bisschen weiter gekommen ist als sie
denn sind genannt sie aber ebenso viele
aktien ist naja heißt frau ernst aber
dritter genau war der vorname ernst
so und jedenfalls nur um kurz die
geschichte zu beenden dann ging es
wieder und zwar diesmal für das gesamte
kabinett also olaf scholz und seine
16 minister acht frauen 8 männer nach
paivas ganz lustig war dass die
eigentlich vorn fast alle mit den
limousinen mit dem blaulicht obendrauf
diesen guten kilometer sind
wahrscheinlich zwei rüber nur im osten
hier vor mit dem fahrer
hübsches ebike art dass ich hört sich
mal anschauen durfte und also er kam da
und er war wie er stolz
präsentiert er war schneller
schneller das war ganz lustig so und
dann gab es die ernennungsurkunden für
die mitglieder des kabinetts und eine
ansprache von unserem bundespräsidenten
und dann gebt geben ging es noch einmal
zurück in den bundestag wo auch alle
minister ihren eid leisten müssen also
viel zum hin und her und hin und her und
heute abend ab 18 uhr soll die erste
kabinettssitzung im bundeskanzleramt
stattfinden davor gibt es die echte du
hast du schon gesagt staffelübergabe der
kanzlerin an den neuen kanzler also
heute nachmittag treffen sich angela
merkel und olaf scholz im kanzleramt und
dann ist angela merkel tatsächlich raus
wir sagen sie will erst einmal durch
schlafen ja das kann man vielleicht auch
ein paar ja oder ja wenn er wirklich
interessant also das war übrigens auch
schon das gleiche bild mehr als jetzt
alle ausgeschieden sind also die
früheren minister ausgeschieden sind und
auch frau merkel ihre abschieds urkunde
bekommen hat oder entlassungsurkunde
muss man ja sagen vom bundespräsidenten
das ist offensichtlich immer so
gestaffelt na also bundeskanzlerin
bundeskanzler ist noch mal was eigenes
sein und dann kommen alle anderen aber
kann man das nicht straffen
ach ich glaube ja dass wir in der
deutschen politik wenn man dass man mit
anderen ländern vergleicht ja relativ
wenig zeremoniell haben das ist ja schon
alles ziemlich
ziemlich nüchtern wir haben nicht so
viele symbole eigentlich also wenn man
das mal vergleicht jetzt zb mit der
amerikaner amtseinführung diese anklage
lang geplant wird und dann also ein
wahnsinns ding da aufgefahren wird mit
künstlern und ich weiß nicht was aus dem
ganzen land aus der mit ehrengästen aus
der ganzen welt und so weiter und
also das ist wer wirklich in deutschland
sehr zurückhaltend und gestern war ich
bei der unterzeichnung des
koalitionsvertrages das war eine
veranstaltung dauerte ungefähr acht
minuten freie szene im futur ii um in
diesem kulturmuseum neben dem
bundesministerium für bildung und
forschung und das war auch der nüchterne
und da haben alle gesagt es ist der
korona pandemie natürlich geschuldet
dass man jetzt hier keine sektkorken
knallen lässt es gab gerade mal ein glas
wasser und ich finde das eigentlich also
ich denke dass es irgendwo auch ein teil
politik dazu gehört auch zum zur
staatlichen repräsentation dass man so
ein bisschen zeigt das ist jetzt eine
zäsur jetzt fängt was neu sein und da
finde ich wenn dann so ein vormittag die
leute bisschen hinterher fahren das ist
ein bisschen kurios aber ist es wirklich
hält sich sehr sehr eingrenzen gehabt
das stimmt gut wie gesagt ist ja auch
tatsächlich etwas etwas neues als
umgekehrt lustigerweise sind ja dann die
die formalia vorneweg werden immer
pompöser also insbesondere der das
verhandeln des koalitions vertrag es ist
ja ein wirklich merkwürdiges konstrukt
inzwischen insbesondere wenn man es
vergleicht zudem wie es mal angefangen
hat also zu beginn der republik da war
natürlich
koalitionsverträge alles andere als
üblich schon gar nicht in der form wie
wir sie jetzt haben der aktuelle hat ja
177 seiten und wurde von wievielen 300
leuten ausgehandelt man bisher 300 leute
die arbeit in gruppen wagen über über
wochen hinweg durch das gerät ich
schnell war diese arbeitsgruppen phase
waren zwei wochen und die wollten am
wochenende nicht arbeiten also wann ist
im grunde zehn arbeitstagen das ist
schon deutlich schneller als in der
vergangenheit aber am anfang gab es das
eben gar nicht also konrad adenauer zu
kana adenauers zeiten war es jedenfalls
so dass so was allenfalls in briefform
hin und her getauscht wurde und das
waren dann auch wirklich nur ein paar
seiten die wohnen auch gar nicht
öffentlich interessant übrigens dass es
da
verfassungsrechtliche bedenken vor allen
dingen gab die es jetzt ja
wahrscheinlich eigentlich immer noch
gibt die aber so ein bisschen gestorben
sind jedenfalls in der öffentlichen
debatte kaum mehr eine rolle spielen
weil vielleicht von ein paar kommentaren
abgesehen aber jedenfalls geht es ja
waren die bedenken lauteten so dass es
ja informelle absprachen netzen enden
letztendlich sind außerhalb des
parlaments zieht dazu geeignet sind das
freie mandat des abgeordneten zu
beschränken also konkret geht es um
artikel 38 des grundgesetzes
festgeschrieben ist dass der abgeordnete
nur seinem eigenen gewissen und der
liegt also die entscheidung frei treffen
kann und da darf ihm eigentlich niemand
reinreden auch nicht parteispitzen die
sich auf einen koalitionsvertrag
geeinigt habe bei das natürlich wirklich
die schöne theorie ist die praxis für
abgeordnete sieht ja ganz anders aus
insbesondere bei
koalitionsfraktionen also bei denen die
regierung tatsächlich tragen da ist ja
wird es ja freundlich umschrieben mit
einer fraktionsdisziplin weil der
fraktionszwang sich natürlich
tatsächlich stoßen für dein artikel 38
aber ich habe kürzlich einen wirklich
sehr interessantes buch gelesen das
heißt hat den schönen titel alleine
kannst du gar nicht sein von den
kollegen 1000 und knapp von der zeit und
und vom spiegel da sind verschiedene
aspekte des abgeordneten lebens sehr
eindrücklich beschrieben und übrigens
auch welche
zwangsmittel
fraktionsvorsitzender hat um
ja widerspenstige abgeordnete
einzufangen dass man zum beispiel damit
droht ihnen den platz im ausschuss
wegzunehmen dass abgeordnete erzählt
haben teilweise anonymisiert erzählt
haben dass sie stundenlang vor dem büro
des fraktionsvorsitzenden warten mussten
was das als art von demütigung
angesehen wurde und ähnliche arten der
druckausübung tatsächlich um sie dazu zu
bringen in kritischen fragen tatsächlich
zuzustimmen das ist wirklich mit dem
sauger theorie in der thalia aber
interessant zu sagen wie sich das hier
entwickelt hat es war vielleicht früher
auch noch anders genau ich glaube da war
in der tat das vielleicht auch noch ein
ideal nachdem man ihr gestrebt hat die
erste schriftliche
und offiziellen koalitionsvertrag wurde
dann bei der bundestagswahl 1961
eingefordert und zwar von der fdp die
hat damals ein wahlergebnis von 12,8
prozent erzielt also einen deutlichen
wahlerfolg und das möglich insofern
interessant als die
koalitionsvereinbarungen damals vor
allen dingen ein ziel hatte nämlich den
damaligen bundeskanzler konrad adenauer
so schnell wie möglich aus dem amt zu
jagen also innerhalb einer halben
legislaturperiode denn eigentlich war
die fdp damals angetreten
um adenauer aus dem amt zu jagen aber
das ist ihr nicht gelungen also sie
musste quasi paktieren mit der union die
hat natürlich an adenauer festgehalten
und den es als bundeskanzler installiert
weiter
so eine weitere legislaturperiode war zu
dem zeitpunkt schon einige jahre lang so
und dann hatte man sich darauf geeinigt
dass er nach der hälfte das amt
verlassen muss und dann
fürchtete man natürlich dass dich sich
der alte nicht daran hält und hat das
biber in einen koalitionsvertrag
gegossen da stand dann eben einfach
drinnen die
koalitionspartner gehen davon aus dass
der vorsitzende der cdu dr konrad
adenauer das amt des bundeskanzlers
nicht für die ganze dauer der
legislaturperiode
bekleiden wird übrigens interessant dass
auch jetzt noch die kleinen und parteien
also grün und fdp ein deutlich höheres
interesse hatten an der an der
detailliertheit sage ich mal des
koalitionsvertrages und übrigens auch
daran dass es überhaupt ein sondierungs
kapiere gab das wollte die spd gar nicht
und dann da haben sich die die anderen
durchgesetzt auch die spd wollte den
koalitionsvertrag so schlank wie möglich
halten und der grund liegt natürlich auf
der hand je weniger im koalitionsvertrag
drinsteht desto mehr kann der kanzler
aus dem kanzleramt kraft seiner
richtlinienkompetenz die dinge
entscheiden und sagen ich mal in
anführungszeichen durchregieren und je
mehr im koalitionsvertrag drinsteht
desto mehr können die kleineren parteien
darauf pochen und sagen moment mal wir
haben aber etwas anderes verabredet also
das was du von damals beschreibt dass
der kleinere partner sorge hatte einfach
übergangen zu werden das lebt auch
tatsächlich noch heute fort und kann man
in der ja in der in dem strickmuster
wenn man so will des koalitionsvertrages
am lesen interessanterweise je weniger
auch zu papier gebracht wird desto
weniger lässt sich dann auch die
koalition daran messen also so genannter
weil da gibt es ja untersuchung die hier
sich diesen den letzten
koalitionsvertrag angeguckt haben das
war robert er kam demokratie experte der
bertelsmann stiftung der sich das mal
angeguckt hat und seine bilanz lautete
dass von den rund 300 versprechen der
groko etwa ein fünftel nicht umgesetzt
worden und manche versprechen tauchen ja
einfach im neuen koalitionsvertrag
wieder auf also zum beispiel auch gerade
die juristischen themen kinderrechte im
grundgesetz
die umsetzung der whistleblower
richtlinie und unternehmens
sanktionenrecht meine ich augen also
diverse dinge die auch teilweise schon
sehr detailliert im früheren
koalitionsvertrag von 217 geregelt waren
sind jetzt einfach übernommen weil sie
nicht umgesetzt wurden man muss
natürlich fairerweise sagen dass jetzt
die pandemie die ja dieses land nun
schon seit fast zwei jahren im griff hat
manches dann unmöglich gemacht hat und
das ja tatsächlich diese 16 jahre angela
merkel 16 jahre waren die von wirklich
so vielen krisen erschüttert waren
migrations krise alles bekannt banken
und finanzkrise da ist es natürlich dann
nicht so ganz so einfach ich bin jetzt
die letzte die da irgendjemand in schutz
nimmt ich will nur sagen was man in
einem jahr vereinbarten kann natürlich
sein dass es einfach zwei drei jahre
später die politische situation oder die
tatsächliche situation so anders ist
dass es einfach nicht mehr passt
deswegen finde ich immer man darf diesen
koalitionsvertrag nicht als etwas
ansehen wo man hinsieht überall kleine
häkchen macht sondern politik reagiert
aber die herausforderung die sich dann
auch in der zeit aktuell stellen wenn
wir jetzt auch keine regierung auf
autopilot die in einem einfach nur jetzt
das abarbeiten was sie da
niedergeschrieben haben übrigens bevor
wir gleich zu den inhalten kommen noch
einmal gesagt er schon der das wort
vertrag ist eigentlich echt zu viel
gesagt denn natürlich ergibt sich daraus
anders als normalerweise aus verträgen
keine rechtliche verbindlichkeit denn
das ist eine politische
absichtserklärung mehr ist es dann auch
nicht gut ankomme zu den themen
ja da fragen wir dann doch mal an mit
dem
migrationsrecht das wirklich ganz
interessante aspekte hat da ist zum
einen bemerkenswert dass die ampel
wirklich erstmals in der deutschen
geschichte
ein klares bekenntnis ab gibt dass
deutschland ein einwanderungsland ist
fast 190 21 werden genauer gesagt das
ist natürlich längst ein
einwanderungsland
die so genannten gastarbeiter kamen in
den 60er jahren nach deutschland damals
dachte man zwar noch sie würden das land
dann auch schnell wieder verlassen was
nicht so war und wir erinnern uns alle
an das einwanderungsgesetz das anfang
der 2000er
erarbeitet wurde was so holprig in kraft
trat war damals ist diese spektakuläre
sitzung gab in dem im bundesrat wo
uneinheitlich abgestimmt wurde dass
deswegen auch den verfassungsrechtlichen
aspekt hat und so ging es dann weiter in
der vergangenen legislaturperiode wurde
das sogenannte fachkräfte ein wohnung
einwanderungsgesetz erarbeitet und
trotzdem auch damals sagte seehofer noch
auf die frage ist deutschland ist ein
einwanderungsland auch der immer warum
müssen sie mich mit diesen schmerzhaften
fragen lässt das sagt ja also und und
auch die spd seite sprach nur von einem
hai fachkräfte einwanderungsland und
wollte eben dieses bekenntnis nicht
abgeben dass es jetzt passiert und
gleichzeitig werden die
rahmenbedingungen dann auch geändert und
angepasst im was deutlich vereinfacht
wird ist die möglichkeit deutscher zu
werden also tatsächlich ist die kann man
eine einbürgerung jetzt schon nach fünf
jahren beantragen und zwar regelmäßig
nach fünf jahren und bei bisherigen bei
besonderen integrationsleistungen sogar
schon nach drei jahren bisher musste man
acht jahre in deutschland gelebt haben
und zwar damit ist natürlich nicht eine
duldung oder so was gemeint sondern ein
regulärer aufenthaltstitels außerdem
sollen kinder von ausländischen eltern
die in deutschland geboren werden schon
von der geburt an deutsche sein
jedenfalls wenn ein elternteil fünf
jahre in deutschland lebt also dass
jasid man für diejenigen die sich dafür
interessieren dass dieses eigentlich
praktizierte houston ruine ist in
deutschland also dass man die
staatsangehörigkeit seiner eltern
bekommt und neben nicht das ewz soli was
ja das klassische recht ist in
einwanderungsländern also etwa in
amerika in amerika geboren wird ist
amerikaner dass sich hier eine art von
verschiebung stattfindet also wir nehmen
uns auch tatsächlich dem amerikanischen
modell ziemlich genau auch in anderen
punkten jedenfalls dem kanadischen
modell mit diesen punkt der
einwanderungssystem
was kommen wird das sozusagen nach den
bedürfnissen des deutschen
arbeitsmarktes ausgewählt werden kann
wer ins land kommen kann neu ist auch
eine ein mittel gegen die sogenannten
kettenduldungen die glaube ich in den
augen aller ein missstand sind also eine
duldung ist ja kein aufenthaltsrecht
sondern es ist im grunde genommen die
eine art von abschiebe verbot wenn man
somit also genau da einfach menschen
hierher und die werden dann eigentlich
werden sie nicht aufgenommen in dem
sinne dass sie hier kein asylrecht
bisschen höher sind wieder anerkannte
flüchtlinge noch haben sie eine asyl
anspruch aber man kann sie aus
verschiedenen gründen nicht abschieben
manchmal liegt es daran dass sie zum
beispiel keine papiere haben oder dass
sie krank sind oder das ist kein dass
irland die einfach nicht zurücknimmt
oder die identität ungeklärt ist oder
aus anderen gründen dann bekommen die
eine duldung das berechtigte sie aber
jedenfalls in der vergangenheit nicht
dazu zu arbeiten und führte eben dazu
dass man menschen hat die hier nicht
wirklich irgendetwas machen können und
das ist natürlich ein problem weil die
sich eigentlich auch nicht integrieren
sollen weil sie ja gar nicht im land
bleiben sollen weil man ihn auch
nahelegt freiwillig auszureisen man kann
sie halt noch nicht abschieben und da
soll jetzt ist jetzt eine idee ein
sogenanntes chancen aufenthaltsrecht zu
schaffen und zwar das gilt für alle
diejenigen die am stichtag erster januar
2022 also jetzt in ein paar wochen seit
fünf jahren oder länger in deutschland
leben und nicht straffällig geworden
sind also das sind all diejenigen die 2
15 bis 2 17 ins land kam und die sollen
jetzt ein jahr einen aufenthaltstitel
bekommen wo sie also auch arbeiten
können um sich da die weiteren
voraussetzungen zusammenzusuchen für
eine echte aufenthaltserlaubnis also zum
beispiel er spielt keine rolle die
die die lebensunterhaltssicherung und
andere fragen
und das ist jetzt eine art von versuch
dass man sagt okay diejenigen die
willens sind sollen sich doch jetzt mal
ein jahr lang anstrengen und dann die
möglichkeit haben ein reguläres
bleiberecht zu bekommen mal sehen ob das
funktioniert ansonsten ist natürlich
sehr sehr viel dass in diesem kapitel
auch noch drin steht zum beispiel dass
ein streitpunkt in
der vergangenen legislaturperiode waren
ja die so genannten sicheren
herkunftsländern da hatten ja vor allem
die grünen aber auch die spd durchaus
bauchschmerzen damit was zur folge hat
dass eben in ländern mit einer geringen
anerkennungsquote sollte das verfahren
eben deutlich schneller gehen und die
sollten auch andere rechte zum beispiel
arbeitsrechte hier nicht so ohne
weiteres haben das ist marokko zb
olympischer ja also da war es genau
umstritten also die koalition in die
große koalition wollte die
maghrebstaaten einstufen und das ist am
widerstand der grünen tatsächlich im
bundesrat gescheitert aber dass ich
sicher herkunftsländer gibt es
insbesondere im westbalkan merkel das
sind die die sind schon zuvor anerkannt
worden
das ist auch wirklich ein symbolisches
thema gewesen und da ist jetzt ganz
lustig so eine art von
jan kompromisslösung dass jetzt die idee
ist dass man so heißt es im
koalitionsvertrag
asylanträge aus ländern mit geringe
anerkennungsquote sollen priorisiert
werden
das ist im grunde genommen eine ganz
ähnliche idee
wenn man auch nicht mehr von sicheren
herkunftsländern spricht dass man muss
natürlich sich genau anschauen was das
im detail dann heißt priorisiert werden
ob da auch tatsächlich das verfahren
deutlich vereinfacht wird oder nicht
also und ansonsten bleibt ist bei
bekenntnissen die wir schon kennen
nämlich irreguläre migration zu
reduzieren und reguläre migration zu
ermöglichen dass man das leid an den
eu-außengrenzen
unterbinden will und das sterben im
mittelmeer das sind natürlich alles
bekenntnisse die auch wichtig und aller
ehren wert sind ebenso wie die arbeiten
an einem gemeinsamen europäischen
asylsystems aber eben auch auf den
vergangenen jahren wie schwierig das
alles ist ja das ist wahrscheinlich ein
versprechen die man dann am ende nicht
halten können wird wenn sie nicht drin
stehen wäre es natürlich aber auch merkt
wert das ist wohl wahr genau also dass
zum thema einwanderung also das ist in
der tat das kapitel wo sich am meisten
tut wo auch wahrscheinlich viel
abverlangt wird von allen beteiligten um
einen großen schritt wagte und das
vielleicht genau also das ist ja nur ein
teil dessen was sich so als
gesellschaftliche modernisierung
beschrieben wird was die ampel sich
vorgenommen hat also was sieht man denn
als politik auf der höhe der zeit die
sozusagen realitäten anerkennen da ist
das ein teil davon bezieht sich auch
darauf also etwa kettenduldungen dass
man sagen na ja die leute sind halt nun
mal hier und dass wir ihnen erklären wir
wollen euch nichts ändert nichts daran
dass sie da sind und wie gehen wir jetzt
mit dieser realität um also jetzt ist
halt immer das liest sich jetzt ganz gut
muss man sagen die frage ist natürlich
immer wie wirkt sich das aus wie
funktioniert das ist es dann doch ein
pull faktor dass leute aus den ländern
denken sie cola in deutschland das ist
ganz einfach da gibt es jetzt das
chancen aufenthaltsrecht oder nicht dass
muss man natürlich genau beobachten ist
natürlich auch ein punkt den die union
jetzt scharf angreift und sagt das
deutet deutlicher linksruck deutlich
liberalisierung die nichts gutes
verheißen lässt ich würde mal sagen ist
es noch zu früh sich da festzulegen
sondern das muss man genau im auge und
so weiter wie so viele es ehrlich gesagt
im koalitionsvertrag kommen wir denn
jetzt mal zu einem zweiten punkt der
auch immer wieder hervorgehoben wird
nämlich das verhasste hartz4 wird es
bald nicht mehr geben ja da ist
natürlich die spd ganz besonders
dahinter gewesen wird es schon lange
loswerden die hat ja sehr gehadert hat
selber eingeführt
2005 ist in kraft getreten auch unter
bundeskanzler schröder wurde erarbeitet
von peter hartz iv vielleicht die die
sich noch daran erinnern das war der
ehemalige vw manager der von schröder
damals beauftragt wurde im jahr 2002
eine arbeitsmarktreform zu erschaffen
die ist dann tatsächlich die in gesetze
gegossen wurde seitdem trägt diese
arbeitsmarktreform seinen namen ich
glaube das sind inzwischen viele nicht
mehr einverstanden inklusive herr harz
hat ja dann auch strafrechtliche
strafrechtliches verfahren wegen
verfehlungen die wiederum im vw-konzern
passiert sind das will ich jetzt gar
nicht vertiefen aber jedenfalls war
vieles an dieser ganzen konstruktion ein
bisschen misslich und deswegen ist man
jetzt glaube ich sehr froh dass man hat
viel los wird und ein bürgergeld schafft
und da ist in der tat die debatte groß
wie stark sich das jetzt von dem
eigentlichen hartz4 konstrukt
unterscheidet und dann wird man nur
sagen müssen also es gibt ein paar dinge
wo man den arbeitslosen entgegen kommt
ja auch direkte erleichterung schafft
auch andere herrschaft aber ich glaube
von dem ganzen grundgedanken kommt man
da nicht runter und ehrlich gesagt finde
ich persönlich das jetzt auch kein drama
ganz im gegenteil denn es war ja auch
vieles ganz gut an der
arbeitsmarktreform na also es geht
natürlich zieht auch immer darauf leute
in den arbeitsmarkt zu bringen das ist
ja das oberste ziel und da gibt es eben
das berühmte fordern und fördern
ich glaube es wurde tatsächlich
umgekehrt eigentlich gerne also erst
das bleibt im wesentlichen es wird am
anfang ein bisschen einfacher denn in
den ersten zwei jahren soll das vermögen
nicht mehr berücksichtigt werden und das
war ja in der tat auch immer etwas was
vielleicht auch für den ein oder anderen
recht hart warne dass man sich
vielleicht was angespart hatte auch für
die altersvorsorge
und dann hieß es das muss muss
verscherbelt werden bevor man überhaupt
hartz 4 beantragen kann und darauf
verzichtet man jetzt in den ersten zwei
jahren war natürlich auch mal ein großer
bürokratischer aufwand es gibt uns
bisher so ein sogenanntes schonvermögen
von maximal 10.000 euro die konnte man
bei seite schaffen klingt jetzt
natürlich ein bisschen
kriminell so war es natürlich gar nicht
gemeint also mein mann konnte musste
nicht alles sozusagen gleich auf
brauchen aber auch das wird jetzt erhöht
also in den ersten zwei jahren sehe das
gar nicht und später soll das
schonvermögen
erhöht werden man kann jetzt sagen wie
ein corona haben wir auch die situation
dass überhaupt die regeln ein bisschen
gelockert wurden denn wir haben jetzt
schon viele situationen von den
selbstständigen die jetzt gar nicht
arbeiten konnten die wirklich von jetzt
auf gleich ins bodenlose gefallen sind
und die dann für die dann auch in der
tat nur hartz iv ihre option war und
schon für die hat man auch diese
vermögens regelung
aufgeschoben nämlich um ein halbes jahr
und das soll jetzt noch großzügige
hergeschaltet
gestaltet werden woran man allerdings
festhalten möchte und das ist eben das
irritiert dann viele die mit hartz4
ohnehin gerade haben sind eben die
sanktionen also das war ja der
hauptstreitpunkt eigentlich an der sache
ja also und da geht es eben darum dass
lange streit ob das überhaupt
verfassungsmäßig ist ob das überhaupt
gekürzt werden darf denn der mechanismus
bei hartz4 beim künftigen bürgergeld
auch ist ja dass man bestimmte
mitwirkungspflichten hatten also man
muss sich einerseits werden regelmäßig
man muss zur verfügung stellen stehen
man muss ansprechbar sein für die
bundesagentur die jeweiligen jobcenter
und sozusagen auf dem arbeitsmarkt zur
verfügung stehen wenn dann job
vermitteln wurde konnte man nicht
einfach so in den wind husten und sagen
ich habe da keine lust drauf sondern man
musste tatsächlich den antreten und man
musste seine
seine bereitschaft signalisieren so und
wenn man das nicht gemacht hat dann gab
es eben verschiedene sanktionen stufen
es fing an mit einer kürzung
von 30 der die hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht muss man dazu
sagen noch abgesegnet die haben gesagt
also das geht aber
darüber hinaus wird schon schwierig also
wenn alles was über 30 prozent
hinausgeht
erklärungsbedürftig also deswegen ist
diese ganze regelung jetzt hier muss neu
reformiert werden vor dieser aufgabe
steht also die ampel koalition auch es
war außerdem schwierig dass er keine
härtefälle vorgesehen wurden und dass es
sogar bis zu einem vollständigen wegfall
der leistung führen könnte also so hart
waren die sanktionen sind sie auch jetzt
noch nur dass man sie im moment
ausgesetzt hat nach diesem urteilsspruch
das war ein urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichts aus dem
februar 2009 10 wo die eben
grundsätzlich gesagt hat ja also
sanktionen sind möglich auch insofern
bemerkenswert als man ja immer gesagt
hat das hat der hartz-iv-regelsatz von
in höhe von glaube jetzt 446 euro
markiert so ein bisschen das
existenzminimum das soziokulturelle
existenzminimum
dass der staat garantieren muss und da
ist natürlich der gedanke wenn man das
kratzt ja dann geht man direkt ans
existenzminimum ran und deswegen was das
jahr gerechnet was gegen die
menschenwürde genau so aber hier also
grundsätzlich ist das möglich also auch
um dieses erfordern dann durchsetzen zu
können aber das wird hier definitiv neu
gefasst also was jetzt hier im
koalitionsvertrag
glaube ich hervorsticht ist die tatsache
dass man daran überhaupt festhalten
möchte das ist tatsächlich sanktionen
geben soll aber auch das klarer bedenken
bekenntnis wir werden die reformieren
wir werden sie evaluieren da gibt man
sich jetzt das ganze nächste jahr zeit
und dann wird man zu einer neuregelung
kommen die zwischenzeit ist das ganze
ausgesetzt was die sanktionen angeht ja
und dann haben wir auch noch ein
was ich auch sehr interessant finde und
was von vielen auch sehr gelobt wurde
insbesondere auch von der fdp die hat er
immer sehr darauf gepocht
dass die
zuverdienstmöglichkeiten gelockert
werden also dass es tatsächlich auch ein
anreiz geben soll sich zu hartz 4 noch
etwas dazu zu verdienen das war wirklich
sehr restriktiv war teilweise grotesk
demotivierend das hat natürlich auch
nicht nur die fdp gesagt sondern das
waren natürlich auch konsens bei spd und
grünen und was natürlich ein ganz
besonders gemein war ist das ja auch
studenten und schüler jobs angerechnet
wurden auf die leistungen der eltern
also dass man auch gerade den jungen
menschen denn gar keine möglichkeit gibt
was nebenher zu verdienen sondern das
dann immer ans amt abgedrückt werden
muss war schon echt gedacht da soll ganz
fallen jetzt ganz entfallen ja das ist
glaube ich die wichtigsten punkte zu hat
vielleicht noch eine sache
entschuldigung zum bürgergeld ist ich
habe mich noch nicht dran gewöhnen
wichtig soll auch sein dass die
weiterbildung und die qualifizierung
also auch da liegt man ein schwerpunkt
darauf dass es geht nicht immer nur
zuerst ums vermitteln sondern auch uns
weiterbilden und qualifizieren und dann
kann man sich auch ein bonus abgreifen
von 150 euro also auch da werden anreize
geschäft geschaffen ja und dann wären
wir jetzt auch noch mal einen kurzen
blick in das kapitel
rechtspolitik immerhin sind wir beim
einspruch broadcast und daher sind es
wirklich eine ganze vielzahl von
kleineren punkten die wir jetzt hier
nicht alle aufzählen können aber eines
möchte ich mal so ein bisschen
allgemeiner sagen das finde ich ganz
interessant und bei der begriff des
rechtsstaats da gibt es ja im grunde
genommen die ursprüngliche bedeutung des
rechtsstaats und das heißt nämlich ein
schutz vor staatlicher willkür also ein
schutz des 1 abwehr recht des bürgers
die bindung des staates an recht und
gesetz und wir sehen ja im politischen
diskurs finde ich jedenfalls eine
bedeutungs verschiebung des begriffs des
rechtsstaats hinzu
wir müssen verbrechen mit der vollen
härte des rechtsstaats verfolgen ja also
das gehört quasi zum ständigen
repertoire jedes bundesinnenministers
auch teilweise jedenfalls in der letzten
legislaturperiode der justizministerin
die also rechtsstaat hat dann mehr sein
diesen aspekt von law and order also
rechtsdurchsetzung und
jetzt fragt man sich wie sieht jetzt die
ampel da drauf die ja immerhin zwei
bürgerrechts parteien
unter sich hat nämlich die grünen und
die fdp und das finde jetzt ganz
interessant da steht im
koalitionsvertrag recht stadt bedeutet
dass wir die regeln unseres gemeinwesens
gegen angriffe verteidigen das lässt
jetzt noch keinen weiteren schluss zu
aber jetzt kommt der nächste satz dazu
gehört der schutz vor kriminalität und
die bewahrung der bürgerlichen
freiheitsrechte also ist eine reparatur
des kreises ja also es ist einerseits
der schutz vor kriminalität ist
natürlich der law and order aspekt und
die bewahrung der freiheitsrechte ist
der aspekt
bindung des staates an recht und gesetz
ihr könnt nicht machen was ihr wollt nur
weil ihr irgendwie
euro-politik durchziehen wollte und wie
man das jetzt auflöst da ist ja
eigentlich eigentliche frage also dass
man sagt wir müssen natürlich unsere
gesetze durchsetzen dass es völlig klar
und es muss auch verbrechen müssen auch
verfolgt werden aber und und
bürgerrechte müssen eingehalten werden
aber wie das dann im konkreten zusammen
geht das ist ja die frage und das löst
jetzt auch dieser koalitionsvertrag
nicht auf aber man kann diese beiden
aspekte darin erkennen und die kann man
übrigens dann auch in den einzelnen
vorschriften erkennen nur mal das
beispiel
strafprozessrecht da steht drin also
strafprozesse sollen effektiver
schneller moderner und praxistauglicher
werden wenn man an schnelligkeit denkt
denkt man natürlich erstmal anja die
bestellung insbesondere von verteidiger
rechten dass die immer als konflikt
verteidiger ja ich sag mal beschimpften
strafrechtler nicht mehr so
ja nicht mehr die richter so mit
irgendwelchen sowieso unzulässigen
anträgen nerven sollen und so weiter ist
aber nicht so gemeint denn im nächsten
satz steht drin ohne die rechte der
beschuldigten und deren verteidigung zu
beschneiden und hier stellt sich wieder
die frage wie geht das eigentlich
zusammen wenn das effektiver und
schneller werden soll aber ein keine
rechte beschnitten werden sollen dann
müssen andere punkte genannt werden die
da aber nicht im einzelnen drinstehen
was wirklich neu ist
ist die das ist das versprechen dass
künftig hauptverhandlungen in bild und
ton aufgezeichnet werden müssen das ist
ja eine häufige forderung gewesen der
anwaltschaft des deutschen anwaltvereins
die gesagt haben es kann einfach nicht
sein dass deutschland als glaube ich
fast einziges land in europa
strafrechtliche hauptverhandlungen nicht
irgendwie dokumentiert sondern da wird
ja tatsächlich auch diese mit schrift
durch den uhr kunst beamten ist ja nur
zeuge com zeugen so sache aus zeuge geht
und zwischendrin wird mal was
protokolliert nur so sehr mühselig nee
das ist nur am amtsgericht als amanda
gericht schreibt der kunst beamte
sinngemäß mit was er so aus der hand
verhandlung oder sie aus der
verhandlungen irgendwie mitnimmt während
im beim landgerichtlichen verfahren ist
es wirklich so dass zur sache außer dass
die anträge oder oder irgendwie sogar
eine andere gemeinde aber nichts zum
inhalt also auch nicht zur zeugenaussage
oder so das heißt es ist schlicht nicht
zu rekonstruieren was eigentlich
gegenstand der hauptverhandlung war und
das macht es dann für die revision
schwierig aber das natürlich auch wo
dann anwälte sagen das ist irgendwie
auch ein totales problem für die rechte
des angeklagten der dann den beweis
glücklicherweise gar nicht führen kann
dass irgendwas vorgetragen wurde also
und man denkt natürlich wie kann es sein
dass etwas mit der stadt findet man es
überhaupt nicht mehr nachvollziehen kann
außer dass die richter selber mit
schreiben ja also es passieren natürlich
das kann man auch den großen prozessen
sehen dass die dann immer alle mit
schreiben was ich journalisten natürlich
nur die journalisten auch und dann man
kennt es ja vielleicht selber von seinen
eigenen mitschriften dass man immer
denkt was habe ich denn damit jetzt
nochmal gemein man kann es vielleicht
nicht mehr richtig lesen und dass es
natürlich gerade bei ganz wichtigen
großen strafprozessen denken wir ein
ende zu die sich über mehrere jahre
hinzieht wobei es da anders war da wurde
glaube ich dokumentiert weil es eine
weitere ausnahme gibt bei großen
verfahren die eine rolle spielen für die
zeitgeschichte dann gab es eine gewisse
lockerung aber keine allgemeine die soll
jetzt also kommen dass es auch für die
anwaltschaft natürlich interessant
ja und dann gibt es noch interessant
auch aus dem bereich des strafrechts
eine ja ein versprechen eine evaluation
vorzunehmen des strafrechts und dabei
den fokus zu legen auf im historisch
überholte straftatbestände und weil man
strebt eine modernisierung des
strafrechts und die schnelle und
entlastung der justiz an das sagt jetzt
erstmal noch nicht ganz genau was damit
gemeint ist es gibt ja einerseits diese
diskussion um überholte
straftatbestände beim mord ja also dass
man irgendwie sagt diese formulierung
wer mörder ist wer würde eben diesen
nicht an die handlung anknüpfen sondern
sozusagen an die ja die persönlichkeit
des täters und das sei und ist auch
tatsächlich strafrecht das ost das noch
den seiner nationalsozialistisches
gedankengut
atmet ob das gemeint das kann ich jetzt
nicht sagen steht das schlicht nicht es
könnte auch sein dass byebye schnelle
entlastung der justiz ist ja eine
forderung von grünen immer gewesen zum
beispiel die erschleichung von
leistungen so zu ändern dass das
schwarzfahren nicht mehr darunter fehler
dass
zu diesen absurden fällen führt dass
leute in
strafhaft sitzen weil sie schwarz
gefahren sind und da sagen ja auch
kriminologen und so weiter das sei
überhaupt kein adäquater umgang damit
ersatz haftstrafe sind ja die fälle in
denen die geldstrafen nicht bezahlt
werden kann und die frage ist ob man
damit tatsächlich die justiz beim
belasten sollte das ist auch in der
union übrigens teilweise kontrovers
diskutiertes gebieten hat den
justizminister aus nordrhein westfalen
der da eigentlich auch eine
entkriminalisierung vorsieht vielleicht
noch einen aspekt zudem den du eben
genannt hast nämlich die quadratur des
kreises an beim rechtsstaat das wird
sich auch in den digital rechten
ziemlich deutlich zeigen also denn die
bürgerrechte oder
die bürgerrechts parteien haben ja
ziemlich deutlich gemacht dass sie die
vorratsdatenspeicherung
nicht machen also und ganz im gegenteil
er auf verschlüsselung gehen und den
bürger also die daten der bürger
schützen wollen und eben nicht den
strafverfolgungsbehörden so preisgeben
wollen wie ist das zum beispiel unter
der union gang und gäbe war das
vielleicht noch eine ergänzung zum thema
rechts bzw digital politik ein wichtiger
hinweis noch betrifft eben die freigabe
von cannabis das ist relativ kurz
gehalten aber umso
bedeutender im koalitionsvertrag eine da
weil er eben drin steht wir führen die
kontrollierte abgabe von cannabis an
erwachsene zu genuss zwecken in
lizensierten geschäften ein also da wird
sich auch einiges tun um das sie haben
eine forderung war übrigens auch
teilweise von von polizeigewerkschaften
also jedenfalls vom bund deutscher
kriminalbeamter die sagen also warum
soll sich eigentlich die
staatsanwaltschaft damit rumschlagen wo
doch sowieso jetzt schon diese ausnahme
für die geringe menge die
gilt die aber eben in allen bunten in
allen bundesländern auch unterschiedlich
gehandhabt wird haben wir dieses
berühmte nord süd gefälle und
also ja dann soll man doch eine klare
ansage machen
und die sehen wir jetzt im
koalitionsvertrag muss natürlich noch
mit leben gefüllt werden an dieser
stelle kann man vielleicht dann nochmals
auf den faz einspruch podcast hinweisen
wo wir tatsächlich über die freigabe von
cannabis schon mal gesprochen haben und
da einen
bericht gehört haben von einem user denn
das dann bitter bereuen musste die
erfolge hieß die bitteren folgen eines
partypoints so und jetzt haben wir die
antwort also das wird eine auf eine
cannabis freigabe in begrenzten
begrenzten rahmen natürlich ne
hinauslaufen interessant ist noch zum
thema schwangerschaftsabbruch da läuft
es auch auf was durchaus grundsätzliches
hinaus also auch etwas was mit der union
niemals möglich gewesen wäre doch so
weit kann man gehen also wir haben den
berühmten
219 a stgb das ist dieser berühmte fall
der gynäkologin
den wir hier auch schon rauf und runter
gesprochen besprochen haben das ist
schon in der tat sogar ein zwei jahre
her so lange ist eben einfach die
diskussion schon am schwelen die hat es
war eben eine ärztin die auf ihrer seite
tatsächlich für eine chance über einen
schwangerschaftsabbruch über die
möglichkeit von
schwangerschaftsabbrüchen
informiert hat und sich da eben dann
anzeigen eingefangen hat auch verurteilt
wurde zu einer geldstrafe aber immerhin
das hat man als fundamental ungerecht
empfunden auch weil das ein einfallstor
war für
abtreibungsgegner die da durchaus rabiat
vorgehen der und ihre kinder für das
interessante an der geschichte oder das
was man wissen muss es halt dieser
paragraph wird immer genannt und so ist
auch die überschrift im strafgesetzbuch
werbung für schwangerschafts abbrüche
tatsächlich ist es aber so dass die
vorschrift jede information über
schwangerschafts abbrüche und das unter
strafe stellt und werbung ist etwas ich
glaube da sind sich wahrscheinlich viele
einig dass man für schwangerschafts
abbrüche nicht werben sollte wie etwa
für eine schönheits op oder ein wellness
urlaub das kann man aber durchaus auch
im standesrecht der ärzte regeln die
frage ist halt was es mit informationen
darüber über die verschiedenen methoden
der abtreibung und ähnliches und das war
halt oder ist immer noch verboten
und führte eben dazu so argumentieren
jedenfalls die ampel parteien das wenn
man im internet frauen im internet heute
nach möglichkeiten der abtreibung suchen
weil sie sich erst mal informieren
wollen dass sie dann auf diese seiten
von abtreibungsgegnern stoßen wo dann
irgendwie furchtbare bilder zu sehen
sind und so weiter und nicht im grunde
in anführungszeichen neutral informiert
werden können
und das ist etwas die das gegenargument
ist natürlich dass in diesem schwierigen
konzept gesamtkonzept des
schwangerschaftsabbruchs oder dass der
recht des rechts des
schwangerschaftsabbruchs dass
bis zur zwölften woche das in
deutschland sowieso straffrei ist aber
dass so das verfassungsgericht
argumentiert dass diese beratung
pflicht
sozusagen der ersatz ist für die
strafbarkeit weil man eben verhindern
will dass sage ich mal einfach so
abgetrieben wird und jetzt ist also
argumentiert die union das zu dieser
beratung eben auch das verbot der
werbung schreckten der information
gehört und dass jetzt dieses ganze
gebilde durcheinandergerät und
möglicherweise dadurch verfassungswidrig
wird das sind alles sicherlich noch
debatten die uns jetzt begleiten vor
allem weil die auch die ampel parteien
ja auch sogar noch weiter gehen und in
der tat dieses ganze gefüge so ein
bisschen außer außer kraft setzen wollen
vielleicht auf neue beine stellen weil
sie in versteht drin ist so eine neue
möglichkeiten geben des
schwangerschaftsabbruchs außerhalb die
sich auf 218 dass man ihnen genau sogar
aus dem strafrecht raus nimmt und dann
wo auch immer verankert das wird man
dann sehen aber die jedenfalls das soll
auch eine überlegung sein die man mal
verfolgt ob es dann tatsächlich nach
vier jahren dann
in der änderung gibt werden wir sehen
aber glaube ich übrigens keine änderung
gibt es ein weiteres vorhaben ist
überhaupt eine liberalisierung der
ganzen fortpflanzungs möglichkeiten im
weiteren sinne also kinderwunsch
möglichkeiten da soll nicht nur die
kinderwunschbehandlung in höherem maße
übernommen werden von den kassen sondern
auch es soll auch eine kommission meine
ich eingesetzt werden die sich mit
fragen von leihmutterschaft oder
millionenspende bmw und spende ist ja
jetzt schon glaube ich da sollen die
möglichkeiten genutzt wenn das ist ja
jetzt schon aufgrund einer
regelungslücke möglich aber von 1e
stände deutschland auch verboten ist die
sollen das eruieren inwiefern das geht
und dass sie natürlich bereiche die
jedenfalls in deutschland bisher echte
tabus gewesen sind genau also da wird es
tatsächlich auch eine womöglich eine
große gesellschaftliche änderung oder
sagen wir erstmal debatte geben dazu
hatte gut also dass zu diesem thema dann
haben wir noch das planungsrecht genau
das ist jetzt etwas ich sag mal hölzern
erklingt heute aber geht natürlich also
ist er wichtiger handelt sich also es
ist vor allem wahnsinnig wichtig für
diese regierung die sich ja nicht
geringeres vorgenommen hat als zwei
prozent der landesfläche windkraft
auszuweisen um halt die energiewende zu
schaffen also wenn eben der
kohleausstieg und der atomausstieg das
alles gleichzeitig passiert damit in
einem industrieland in deutschland
weiterhin strom aus der steckdose kommt
muss er irgendwoher kommen und deswegen
sagen sie setzen auf windkraft und solar
und die frage die sich sofort stellt
deshalb wie soll man diese ganzen
windräder bauen wenn man weiß wie
wahnsinnig langsam in deutschland
geplant und gebaut wird und das
großvorhaben und dazu gehören natürlich
auch windparks wirklich ewig brauchen
und mit ex klagen und ich weiß nicht was
belegt werden und da hat die ampel
natürlich gemerkt dass sie daran müssen
wenn das überhaupt klappen soll das hat
auch schon die vorherige koalition
versucht mit mehreren
planungsbeschleunigungsgesetz die alle
bis jedenfalls bisher keine
durchschlagende wirkung haben und jetzt
soll also ziel ist die planungs die
verfahrensdauer für investitionen
mindestens zu halbieren das ist eine
echte ansage
so und da müssen wir jetzt auch nicht im
klein-klein
sagen wie das alles gemacht werden so es
ist wirklich ganz viele kleine
stellschrauben an denen die ampel drehen
will was sie nicht machen will ist ja
das was einen auf den allerersten blick
ein feld nämlich verfahrensrechts zu
beschneiden also man einfach sagt lagen
was oft diskutiert würde auch von der
union vorgeschlagen wurde also dass man
sagt am einfachsten ist es natürlich es
gibt keinen rechtsschutz mehr dann kann
keiner klagen dann gibt es auch keine
langen gerichtsverfahren dann steht das
die sache einfach so einfach geht s
natürlich sowieso nicht aber da sagt
auch die ampel oder der
koalitionsvertrag das würde gar nicht so
viel bringen
abgesehen davon dass es tatsächlich aus
europarechtlichen gründen und auch es
möglicherweise verfassungsrechtlichen
und gar nicht so einfach ist also
andreas scheuer der bis heute
bundesverkehrsminister ist hatte ja mal
ein gesetz gemacht das sogenannte
maßnahmen gesetzt wo es hieß in zukunft
sollen einfach große
infrastrukturprojekte per gesetz
erlassen werden dann kann man halt
dagegen vom verfassungsgericht klagen
als bürger aber nicht eben ganz normal
irgendwie einfach so vom
verwaltungsgericht und
dann ist die sache erledigt da gab es
einen verfahren vom europäischen
gerichtshof und der hat gesagt nee so
nicht da deutschland wurde verurteilt
wegen verstoß gegen die
gegen eine europäische richtlinie die
eben besagt dass es
rechtsschutzmöglichkeiten gibt die ampel
will also im gegensatz geradezu die
öffentlichkeit intensiver und viel
früher beteiligen weil die erfahrung ist
dass die erfahrung von robert habeck aus
in seiner zeit als umweltminister und
neue energieminister einschließlich
deutschland als er sagte wenn man sehr
sehr früh mit den menschen spricht und
sie einbindet und versucht ihre belange
zu berücksichtigen und alles zu bündeln
dann würde es auch später weniger klagen
geben man muss jetzt ein bisschen gucken
das klingt natürlich gut die frage ist
inwiefern funktioniert das dass es in
einem kleinen land wie
schleswig-holstein funktioniert heißt
natürlich nicht dass es im ganzen bund
funktioniert die bundesregierung ist
natürlich auch sehr viel weiter weg von
den leuten vor ort als jetzt eine
landesregierung insofern ist wirklich
dann die frage wie das umgesetzt werden
soll
ansonsten gibt es noch einen anderen
aspekt der ganz wichtig ist und der das
wirklich schwierige verhältnis zwischen
klimaschutz und artenschutz betrifft
nämlich die frage also bislang war es
ebenso ein verstoß gegen den artenschutz
und das kann auch bedeuten dass es für
bestimmte bedrohte vogelarten einfach
mauser plätze geben muss oder ähnliches
und diese in es gibt ja wirklich sehr
viele bedrohte tierarten ich habe jetzt
kennengelernt die zierliche teller
schnecke auch schon das eine oder andere
vorhaben gestoppt wird in hamburg
insbesondere genau und bisher war sie
ebenso es gibt zwar
artenschutzrechtliche ausnahmen also
wenn gegen das datenschutzrecht
verstoßen wird dann kann das
ausnahmsweise trotzdem einbau erlaubt
werden aber nur dann wenn es im
öffentlichen interesse steht und im
öffentlichen interesse steht nicht so
viel und jetzt also klar gestellt im
koalitionsvertrag jedenfalls vorbereitet
dass klimaschutz künftig ein
öffentliches interesse ist das heißt man
kann jetzt künstlich eine abwägung
vornehmen
ob eben in dem fall der klimaschutz
wichtiger ist als der schutz einer
bestimmten art das wird also tatsächlich
in der in der frage der genehmigung sich
dann
auswirken genau da lässt man natürlich
die arten daneben deine teller schnecke
dann auch nicht alleine sondern hat
andere ideen wie man die dann fördert
durch artenschutzprogramme zum beispiel
da geht es sozusagen darum die
population als ganzes oder überhaupt zu
fördern und nicht quasi jeder einzelne
schnecke die da über den jeweiligen
platz kriegt vielleicht noch einen
allerletzten punkt der zeigt wie
schwierig die ganze sache ist es gibt
auch eine überlegung jetzt eine
präzision zu erlauben nämlich für den
fall also präzision heißt man darf die
rechte einfach nicht mehr wahrnehmen
also man dagegen ein vorhaben nicht mehr
vorgehen weil es plädiert weil sozusagen
das eigene recht rekrutiert ist und da
das ist in dem fall möglich künftig soll
es möglich sein in dem ein
naturschutzverband oder ein nachbar oder
ein betroffener bürger überhaupt gar
nichts gemacht hat also zu keinem
zeitpunkt deutlich gemacht hat dass er
irgendein problem mit diesem vorhaben
hat und wenn er dann sehr spät damit
kommt also nach der genehmigung dann
sagt man jetzt bist du mit deinem mit
seinen einwänden hier rekrutiert das ist
auch wirklich die winzige kleine lücke
die der ogh in diesem fall lässt und die
hat jetzt die ampel diese kleine lücken
jetzt die ampel genutzt nämlich
tatsächlich hat mich damit man deutlich
länger beschäftigt mit einer fahne
verwaltungsrechtler gesprochen nämlich
dem professor eva der ehemals mal
präsident des deutschen anwaltvereins
war und er erzählte mir wirklich sehr
interessant wie sehr dieses kann sich
der ganze bereich von europarecht aber
auch teilweise vom nationalen recht aber
auch vor allem von der rechtsprechung
des europäischen gerichtshofs
eingemauert ist dass man sehr sehr wenig
tun kann und dazu kommt noch sagen ich
mal die deutsche gründlichkeit in
anführungszeichen das eben kein anderes
land in europa diese probleme hat weil
in deutschland das dann alles auch noch
so wahnsinnig genau befolgt wird und
bewilligungsbescheide bei uns dann halt
ein paar tausend seiten haben und er
erzählte mir dann das für ein ganz
ähnliches vorhaben in den niederlanden
dann halt 30 seiten geschrieben werden
und jetzt sagt er zur flora fauna
habitat richtlinie
schwierige frage die die schwierigen
fragen des naturschutzes regel ist dann
halt bei den holländern ein kleiner
absatz und man trifft sich und löst das
ganz pragmatisch und in deutschland sind
keine ahnung 300 seiten zur flora fauna
habitat richtlinien das ist halt dann
immer alles auch noch sehr sehr
schwerfällig und dann gibt es referenten
die sind dann sehr sehr stolz drauf dass
sie im unter absatz 5 satz 4 noch einen
begriff finden der auch vielleicht
anders ausgelegt werden könnte ich bin
jetzt polemisch ich weiß aber es ist
wahrscheinlich ziemlich heiß ist dann so
eine merkwürdige mischung aus ist es
alles europarechtlich überlagert aber
andere länder kommen dann damit und also
nicht nur überlagert sondern auch waren
sich kompliziert aber andere länder
kommen da dann irgendwie besser mit klar
als als wir das ist insofern wirklich
nicht einfach und man muss echt mal in
vier jahren genau gucken ob es geschafft
ob diese ampel ist geschafft hat das
würde mich muss ich ehrlich sagen stand
heute wundern wenn die es schaffen die
verfahrensdauer zu halbieren sehr
interessant gut also aber das wäre jetzt
alles was wir an highlights aus dem
koalitionsvertrag hervor tragen sie
wollten sich seiten genau kann man sich
ansonsten schön weil zwischen den jahren
unmöglich auf dem sofa natürlich zu
gemüte führt haben wir die letzten dinge
wie daran hindern aber mehr können wir
jetzt acht wirklich beim besten willen
nicht vortragen
weil wir jetzt noch einen letzten
schlenker machen müssen zum
infektionsschutzgesetz das war jetzt
schon zum 75 mal im bundestag in einer
woche
es wurden tatsächlich auch ad hoc sehr
schnelle sitzung einberufen am
dienstagnachmittag zum beispiel am
freitag wird auch noch mal darüber
gesprochen weil es da noch etwas ich sag
mal klärungsbedarf gab weil auch neue
dinge hinzugekommen sind die können wir
jetzt hier nun mal relativ schnell
referieren die dinge die geklärt werden
mussten waren also an welchen punkten
oder welche einrichtungen geschlossen
werden dürfen und welche nicht da haben
wir gesehen durch die schlaufen die das
jetzt gedreht hat kam es dazu einer
gewissen
rechtsunsicherheit also die berliner zum
beispiel waren der festen überzeugung
dass man eine klubs nicht schließen darf
und dass man deswegen nur ein tanzverbot
verhängen darf auf basis des schon
geänderten infektionsschutzgesetzes in
nordrhein westfalen hat man das anders
gesehen und die klubs kurzerhand
geschlossen die frage ist wer hat nun
recht und deswegen hat man das jetzt
deutlicher gefasst im
infektionsschutzgesetz und hat auch die
gastronomie die geliebte gastronomie
wobei ich nicht zu sagen haben sind
eigentlich klubs gehören auch gar nicht
zur gastronomie das war nämlich auch
immer in die argumentation warum zum
beispiel die geschätzte
rechtswissenschaftlerin andrea kießling
man gesagt hat sie weiß gar nicht wo die
aufregung besteht denn die die klubs
gehörten ihrer ansicht nach zu den
freizeiteinrichtungen dir geschlossen
werden na ja vor allem tanzt und dann
erst redet ihr gemacht und dann auch
sehr so wenig also zu wenig jedenfalls
wasser und
wie auch immer also jedenfalls im was
jetzt neu in der tat hinzugekommen ist
eigentlich wollte man die gastro offen
halten aber damit ist es jetzt nun auch
vorbei wenn man sagen die sind es gibt
jetzt die möglichkeit der einschränkung
genau das war ja also dass er ganz
interessant dass diese ausrufung der
epidemischen lage durch die länder ist
jetzt eben im hat steht jetzt im gesetz
eine auflistung was man alles nicht da
also ist es sozusagen nicht nicht was
ist was kann man verbieten so etwas darf
man nicht verbieten und da sind eben die
bekannten dinge über die ihn ja auch
schon gesprochen hatte nämlich ausgangs
beschränken dürfen nicht mehr verhängt
werden schulen sollen nicht geschlossen
werden und so weiter und die frage ist
und ist bisher stand auch schon drin
freizeit und kultureinrichtungen
dürfen aber geschlossen werden also die
waren sozusagen nicht aus genau
aufgenommen sondern da stand nur was
drin von religiösen veranstaltungen also
gottesdienste
und so weiter
und dann ging es hin und her mit der
frage der weil es auch wirklich einfach
gesetzgeberisch extrem kompliziert ist
weil man dann irgendwie in den anderen
katalogen muss was da eigentlich
verboten werden kann und das dann
jeweils abgleichen muss und der schönen
sommer wirklich nicht schön und dann
stand da auch immer noch dann wurde
argumentiert naja wenn man man kann ja
die person überzahl begrenzen und wenn
man jetzt zum beispiel bei der
gastronomie sagt personen oder zahlen
unserem in unseren restaurants aber zwei
personen dann ist das taktisch
geschlossen sondern war die gegenseite
argumentiert na ja aber da steht ist die
rede davon du darfst weder
schließen noch begrenzen und das ist ja
eindeutig eine begrenzung also es war
wirklich aufgrund dieser
gesetzgebung dieser verweise
untereinander einfach sehr unklar jetzt
ist klargestellt dass eben dieser ganze
bereich bis hin zu restaurants auch
geschlossen werden können wenn die
länder die epidemische lage ausrufen und
das dann entsprechend auch so in ihrer
verordnung reinschreiben wichtig ist
dass es jetzt auch mit der impfpflicht
losgeht zunächst einmal mit einer
einrichtungs bezogenen impfpflicht die
wird verankert in § 20a
infektionsschutzgesetz ist mit sehr
langem vorlauf geplante denn das ganze
muss erst vollzogen sein oder oder
entfaltet überhaupt erst wirkung am 15
märz bis dahin mögen sich bitte alle
impfen vollständig impfen übrigens die
in den genannten einrichtungen
arbeiten dazu zähle neben altenheime
krankenhäuser
da war vieles neu
einrichten
hier ist wirklich ja auch übrigens
apotheken und
zahnärzte und arztpraxen und auch so was
wie heilpraktiker und so weiter also es
ist er ist eine sehr sehr lange liste
eben alle
einrichtungen in denen menschen sich
aufhalten die besonders gefährdet sind
also krank alt oder sonst passieren so
und jetzt ist genau passiert genau das
war es übrigens auch professor kingreen
auch schon in einem podcast hier bei uns
prophezeit hat nämlich dass es dann
schwierig wird in die abgrenzung zu
gehen dass es da womöglich klagen gibt
gegen artikel 3 willkürliche
ungleichbehandlung die davon staaten
gegner also warum sind da zum beispiel
kita erzieher und lehrer nicht drin es
gibt auch noch etliche andere die mit
variablen gruppen zusammenarbeiten die
nicht explizit genannt wird also die im
moment noch keiner endlich und der
liegen ja und das ist natürlich
komplizierter als bei einer allgemeinen
impfpflicht wo man einfach sagt jeder
über 18 oder wie auch immer muss geimpft
werden also wir steigen jetzt hier
wirklich in die sehr
delikate
diskussion ein um die impfpflicht und da
bin ich auch noch wirklich sehr gespannt
wie die diskussion weitergeht letzter
punkt zu diesem bereich das natürlich
auch noch mehr leute überhaupt impfen
können also insbesondere apotheker und
und tierärzte und übrigens mit den
apothekern das habe ich verwechselt die
dürfen jetzt impfen die müssen aber ich
habe gerade noch mal schnell
reingeschaut in den 20 a
die sehe ich hier nicht also ich hab ja
vorhin gesagt da auch apotheker geimpft
sein müssen auf den ersten blick sehe
ich die jetzt hier jedenfalls nicht
sondern es sind arzt also ärzte also
mitarbeiter von arztpraxen also auch die
ja die sag ich mal frauen männer die am
empfang sitzen und die
medizinisch-technischen assistentin und
in zahnarztpraxen also kleine korrektur
schon in der sendung ja das besser
besser als nie
genau aber dieses diesen kleinen
nachtrag wollten wir uns noch können
dann kommen wir jetzt zum gerechten
urteil
so und das was für ist das perfekte
gerechte urteil der woche des es
verbindet beide themen die wir zunächst
enter besprochen haben nämlich
einerseits die bundeskanzlei am ural und
den infektionsschutz auch wirklich also
kongeniale reisen das verfassungsgericht
tun haben uns sehr gut zum aussagen hfg
also auch hier die besten natürlich
gebraucht aber westlich hätte die hat
eben tatsächlich oft auch die fhf die in
diesem zusammenhang es hat nämlich elf
abgeordnete der afg geklagt weil sie so
wahnsinnig gerne heute an der kanzler
wahl teilnehmen wollten an der sitzung
eine sehr wichtigen historischen sitzung
im bundestag und sich daran gehindert
sein und zwar durch die 2g regel die in
berliner hotels geht und die in
paragraph 19 des
infektionsschutzgesetzes des landes
berlin verankert ist so und da haben sie
eben gesagt diese
diese regelung hindert uns quasi an der
ausübung unseres recht als freier
abgeordneter also da wieder auch artikel
die auch sonst im hotel also und zwar
war es wohl so es sind wohl elf die
abgeordnete die außerhalb von berlin
wohnen sonst hättest erinnert hat keinen
sinn man weiß nicht hundertprozentig wo
die wohnung es gibt einige die haben das
gar nicht so genau dargelegt wie weit
sie eigentlich an reisen müssen und das
war wurde ihnen dann auch rechts und
links um die ohren gehauen vom
bundesverfassungsgericht aber die haben
eben gesagt also jetzt wir haben keine
wohnung hier wir müssen in hotels und
deswegen und weil wir das nicht können
ja wir sind eben nicht geimpft weil sie
wollten jetzt nur zur kanzlerwahl dasein
und beabsichtigen gar nicht in zukunft
überhaupt im parlament zu erscheinen
oder es ging tatsächlich jetzt doch es
war ein gesamtpaket also zum einen
wollten sie ihm am 8 dezember dabei sein
um 9 uhr gesagt hast ja schon erzählt
fing es eben an am folgetag am 9
dezember beginnt um 9 uhr die nächste
plenarsitzung des deutschen bundestags
auch sehr wichtig und dann finden am 10
dezember also dann am freitag eine
äußerst wichtige sitzung der fraktion
stadt ja an denen die auch teilnehmen
wollen also eine fülle an
übernachtungsmöglichkeiten und
ihre argumentation war eben dann auch so
sehr auf die typisch möchte ich mal
sagen
haben dargelegt dass corner impfung eine
weitergabe des virus und dritte gerade
nicht ausschließen was ja stimmt dass in
dieser teil ist richtig aber sie gingen
so weit zu sagen dass es eben kein grund
dafür gebe die geimpften oder genesenen
menschen zu privilegieren gegenüber
leuten die einfach nur ein test vorlegen
können ja und zwar weil alle drei
gruppen etwa ein verhältnismäßig
gleiches infektionsrisiko aufweisen und
das würde glaube ich das
anders sehen so und interessant wie hat
das bundesverfassungsgericht reagiert
haben die gestern nachmittag also am
dienstagnachmittag zurückgewiesen und
zwar in zwei punkten komplett
abgeschmettert das eine war eben dass
sie gesagt haben also die
verfassungsbeschwerde ist schon komplett
unzulässig weil sie ja den subsidiarität
grundsatz nicht eingehalten haben also
die hätten ehrlich gesagt vom
verwaltungsgericht erst einmal
vorstellig werden müssen ja und da muss
man auch sagen ich glaube das war auch
wieder so ein bisschen
quasi die afg nebelkerze wo man
natürlich gleich ganz obenan fängt
gleich zum bundesverfassungsgericht
gleich lichtwirkung wahrscheinlich genau
und gar nicht erst den den weg
einheiten möchte weil man natürlich auf
die große bühne möchte das hat sich das
bundesverfassungsgericht nicht mit sich
machen lassen hat gesagt sie hätten ihm
den
subsidiarität grundsatz beachten müssen
und erst in rechtsweg ausschöpfen müssen
und die fachgerichte können ja auch die
verordnung verwerfen wie wir es schon
weiß gott auch aus berlin hier gesehen
haben
und also das war die eben der eine punkt
und der zweite punkt war eben auch dass
es schon materiell nicht begründet wurde
weil sie eben teilweise auch nicht
deutlich dargelegt haben ja wie weit sie
eigentlich andere reisen ob es jetzt
wirklich auf die berliner hotels
angewiesen sind die haben die cent
darauf hingewiesen dass zum beispiel es
in brandenburg eine ausnahme gibt für
berufliche gründe ja also tatsächlich in
potsdam hätten sie unterkommen können
oder wo auch immer gebrannt hat er viele
schöne seiten wenn man sich ein hotel
suchen kann um dann nach berlin
einzureisen um rechtzeitig um 9 uhr
morgens da zu sein also das hat die
karlsruher richter nicht überzeugt und
schließlich haben sie gesagt also diese
zweijährige der berliner hotels hat
zählt schon auch gar nicht auf artikel
38 grundgesetz also sie die ist nun
wirklich allenfalls über umwege dazu
geeignet das recht der
abgeordneten
einzugreifen und das finden wir einfach
zutiefst gericht also zum einen weil wir
denken dass sie sich eigentlich auch
einfach impfen lassen können aber das
ist jetzt natürlich kein rechtliches
argument aber es ist schon auch einfach
ich finde es vor allem unter dem aspekt
dass hier wieder rechtsweg so benutzt
wird um eigentlich für das eigene
politische vorhaben zu werben und
nicht weil es irgendwie wirklich so ist
dass irgendjemand gehindert wäre an
dieser sitzung teilzunehmen weil er
in berlin nicht im hotel übernachten
kann also zumal man sich ja wirklich
fragt wenn man hier abgeordneter ist und
sein mandat ernst nimmt dann ist es
sowieso wäre es nicht schlecht
hier eine art von
sag ich mal dauerhaft da würde man jetzt
denken dass das vielleicht neu ordnen
sind aber ich sage ja bei alice weiter
vielleicht und dann kommt
bei wem auch immer wie gut wir bedanken
uns ganz herzlich bei der aufmerksamkeit
ich mich bei dir lena dir kommen
deswegen heute hier sehr gemütlich
zusammenhocken durften ja also machen
sie es gut macht es gut schöne rest
woche wir haben uns nächste woche
nächste woche wieder da bin ich dann mit
pia dann wieder dabei
[Musik]